we have about a thousand people that we
have taken
from the barons hotel for further
processing
uh afghan both under the arap scheme and
the leave outside the rules and british
nationals and they will be leaving
during the day how much longer can we do
this for well we at 4 30 this morning
the uk time closed the barrens hotel
shut the processing center and the gates
were closed abby gate and
we will process those people that we
have brought with us the thousand people
approximately inside the airfield now
and we will seek a way to
continue to find a few people in the
crowds where we can but overall the main
processing has now closed
and we have a matter of hours
i was speaking to a translator in the
last at the end of the last hour i'm
saying he's stuck with his wife and his
family and he can't get out and if he
stays there he'll die can we help him
well we can help him um we can't help
him as
you know optimally as we like right now
obviously we've had to close the hotel
where we did the processing
uh the majority we've got out
approximately uh 13 000 people
from the arap interpreter scheme and the
people that helped the ministry of
defence and the wider government network
but as i've said repeatedly for really
the last two weeks the sad fact is not
every single one
will get out
we will make sure that we have our visa
processing centers or indeed our
enhanced capabilities in
around the region and those neighboring
countries and and people who can should
make their way to that third country and
we will
be for them it depends where they are um
it also depends i think in the roles
they're in
and we will give them advice about how
they can make their way somewhere but
also how they can look after themselves
at the moment but at the same time as
the g7 said
we're going to work quite hard with the
international community to put pressure
on the taliban
to honor uh you know
the international obligations of
afghanistan to make sure that we give
those people as much as possible a safe
passage
and we do our very best by them
it does look like it's one of our planes
you were telling me if they've got a
white stripe on the back then that's
that's an american plane that doesn't
look as though it does when you see that
go up into the air like that it means
another several hundred people coming
back to the uk that must give you some
satisfaction look i i i think we've had
almost one of the biggest airlifts of a
generation extraordinary
amount of effort by the raf and our
forces at risk and you know when we went
two weeks ago under op pitting on the
14th of august we went specifically for
this purpose we weren't we weren't there
to do other tasks we were there to
secure the airport and to get as many
people out as possible and you know it's
heading towards nearly 16 000
overall since april and you know nearly
14 000 since 14th of august that's
nearly a thousand people a day
both british nationals and afghan
refugees to some extent or certainly
afghans who helped us throughout the
process
it it does but it doesn't temper the
overall feeling about what we're doing
leaving afghanistan after 20 years and
nor does it sort of temper the fact
there are still people that are going to
be in afghanistan that we couldn't get
out
given that you've closed the processing
center now not least because there was
an explosion um outside the hotel which
is where one of the processing centers
was um how many more planes before
that's it i don't i don't know the slots
but roughly they were running at eight
nine a day uk planes you saw those big
planes there taking off the c-17s we
could if we have to vary the number of
people allowed in it we could break all
the regulations i authorized early on uh
a loosening of the regulation so we
could pack people in if we had to that
was you know the risk i thought was the
right to take and so we can do that
we have to now start removing the
thousand british forces they have to get
out as well the the amazing uh work that
they've done from 16 air assault brigade
their parachute regiment
and and indeed the other regiments
supporting them the yorks and the rifles
have done an extraordinary job and so
they have to get out as well out by the
31st or before within before uh i can't
i'm not going to give you for
operational reasons the actual date but
the u.s have been very clear they're
going to leave on the 31st of august the
the one thing i will move out before
then yeah we have to they will be the
last people out and i you know my
thoughts today are with the families of
the 13
u.s soldiers killed uh yesterday and
indeed the you know approximate 80 to 90
afghans killed as well you know those
are we shouldn't forget with all the the
turmoil that we see in the united states
at the moment the u.s put the
overwhelming force into that airport to
help us secure it over five to you know
about five to six thousand troops and it
is u.s troops who died yesterday
protecting that operation and i think
we have to be thankful for that and
grateful that they have enabled us to do
much of what you're seeing on the telly
and should we grieve for the taliban
fighters that died as well
i i agree for all loss of life that is
unnecessary i think it is pretty awful
uh what has happened to afghanistan in
50 60 years both with the soviet
invasion its poverty the the death we've
seen on the streets that the huge loss
of life of the afghan army we shouldn't
forget the brave afghan army that stood
in front of the taliban lost nearly 70
000 people fighting them
and i think we we shouldn't forget that
and i
i you know the taliban
are have been our adversary have been
our enemy uh over those last 20 years
they have killed you know over 400
british soldiers
in actions uh so i'm not going to uh sit
and say that you know i
am you know pleased by what i see today
and yesterday with the taliban what i
would say
is that you know the loss of life the
attack by people like isis i mean what
what purpose was that going to serve to
blow up innocent people or all people
standing trying to leave the country
under humanitarian flies that is a truly
evil specter that we face in the name of
isis it's why isis is something we take
on all over the world where it poses an
imminent threat to the united kingdom
are you uh what's intelligence saying
about any other threats in the next
couple of days or so well the threat is
obviously going to grow the closer we
get to leaving i think in a generic form
the narrative is always going to be as
we
leave uh certain groups such as isis
will want to stake a claim that they
have driven out the u.s or the uk
and i think what i should make clear to
your viewers is that we close the barons
hotel almost exactly on schedule the
explosion was horrendous
but it didn't hasten our departure we
were going last night uh and that was
always going to be once the us had
decided the 31st of august uh was the
final date okay but as far as live
threats are concerned is there any
intelligence to say that there's we
always have a we have a range of
intelligence there's quite a lot of
threat out there that's why we think
there's a highly likely and an even
greater risk of attack
to our forces and to afghans it's why
yesterday the foreign office beginning
of the day issued the stay away from the
airport as soon as that became real
there was a very clear warning now
that's easier said than done if you were
one of the thousands around the gate
and in fact the night before the british
army and others had pushed away from the
barons hotel a standoff uh area so up to
about 300 meters away from the barons
hotel and that is in fact where the
bomber uh detonated we think uh himself
uh at that um standoff so you know in in
recognition of the amazing work armed
forces did if they hadn't pushed that uh
perimeter further out i think we could
have been in worse place but of course
the americans we shouldn't forget the
loss of life from them they'll be
sending back 13 men
and maybe women who died in action and i
think that is a real uh something very
sad for us all
what is the latest on casualty figures
do we have them so sadly an american
died overnight my understanding is is
currently at 13
killed in action united states service
personnel uh considerable number of
injured that is obviously to be firmed
up as a number and about 60 to 80
afghans also tragically lost their lives
and they will have included obviously
families waiting in the canal or by the
canal for processing and the uk military
we were very lucky we've had no
deaths as yet from the both this
operation and indeed uh yesterday uh but
of course uh that is uh you know
good professionalism but it's not all in
the hands of our soldiers it depends
what the bombers went it could have been
us it could have been us
are the taliban our foes or our allies
well i think at the moment what i'd say
is the taliban are running the country
and that is the simple fact we find
ourselves in that country and we have to
extract once that is over we have to
make a decision about our relationship
with the taliban we want afghanistan to
hold to its international obligations
that it's signed up to under the former
government
we want to make sure that the afghan
government or regime that it becomes
doesn't host al-qaeda
does something about isis
and lives to its actions that it
proves with his actions that its new
words mean something i i think the jury
is out on that i think for now
they have
uh you know our local level our forces
have engaged with them and they have
given us space to get people out but as
you've seen in the last 48 hours they've
started to tighten that screw turn back
afghans and they've let through british
passport holders but they've been
turning back afghans
a couple of points uh before i let you
go i know you're very busy this morning
um the u.s has said that it's sharing
intelligence with the taliban including
biometrics um
to try and find out what's
getting people in and also
concerned about further attacks um
that's quite a dangerous thing to do
isn't it
well i mean i can't speak for another
country what we do that's what i'm
saying
in our country the rules of how and who
we share intelligence with are guided by
regards for human rights we we are very
cautious about how we share intelligence
with a nation who doesn't have the same
human rights standards with us obviously
we have to find sometimes a pragmatic
way through if it means
we deal with an imminent threat to
ourselves but overall
we have lots of rules that govern that
we can't just hand out intelligence to
people as we feel it but um look
we're in business of leaving afghanistan
today and over the next few days
and uh i don't think you know if if
there's an imminent threat to life so
let's say we know someone is coming with
a bomb directly towards us or towards
other afghanis and we knew that
yesterday we well i can't speculate on
on exactly the detail we know we knew
there was an imminent threat um and
that's what we publicly talked about i
can't say to what extent we knew
and also whose intelligence it was it
may you know it
the people who are in the intelligence
are the ones who get the right to decide
how they share it final thought
how will history view our involvement in
afghanistan
i think history is getting a view
this century's involvement in the early
part of this century
is asking the west the question which is
the west seems to think it fixes
problems rather manages problems you
know the west seems to think it flies in
does a few things and everything's going
to be all right and
you don't fix problems like afghanistan
a thousand years of of tribal fighting
war
uh you manage them and if you wish to
engage in nation building or supporting
a nation you're probably best off doing
it as a international body you know we
did it as nato but but
you know i think you're best off doing
that and you need to be prepared there
for the long run you know we we were in
germany uh tom tugan had my
foreign office my colleague who chairs
the foreign office committee you know he
talked about how long we were in the
cold war um you know they're long things
they're long events and you should be
prepared to do that and i think that's
the lesson and if not
then find another way and that's our
relationship with the united states been
damaged as a result of what's happened
no i mean
are you sure yeah look look our
relationship with the united states is
is like a family and you know you know
we have siblings we are friends uh we
have
at all levels of the relationship we
have those type of cultural ties and
friendships and that's the real in my
experience special relationship you know
presidents come and go prime ministers
come and go in office
but our deepest relationship is both
economic and cultural and you know that
if i go tomorrow to any american
headquarters whether it is in hawaii
where i visited uh in the earlier part
of the summer you'll find one or two
brits right in the heart of their
headquarters working alongside the
united states
you and i won't know their names
they won't be great admirals or generals
of the highest order
but they're there alongside each other
and that's the special relationship
it's great to talk to you i know you've
got a busy morning so i must let you go
thank you very much indeed and thanks
for um talking us through the planes
leaving at kabul airport thank